-Welcome back, everybody!
It's time to play,
"Can You Feel It?"
♪♪
-[ Scat singing ]
-♪ Can You Feel It? ♪
-But I'm going
to need some help.
Her new movie,
"Being the Ricardos,"
[ Drumroll ]
is in theaters December 10th
and on Prime Video
December 21st.
Please welcome the one
and only Nicole Kidman!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-♪ Can You Feel It? ♪
♪♪
You told me to come here.
-Oh, yeah.
I'm here.
-Well, wow.
-[ Laughs ]
-Nicole, Nicole...
-Mwah!
-...here's how this works,
alright?
-Yes.
-We're going to have
a number of mystery objects
-Oh, boy.
-brought out in front of us
and our job is to guess
what each one is.
The catch is that we have
to figure it out
by touch, alone.
Are you ready for this?
-I am so ready.
[ Cheering ]
-Really? Alright.
Since I'm the host --
here we go --
I'm going to go first.
Why am I going first?
Let's --
Alright,
let's see our first object.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, so this is --
Alright,
I'm not good at this game.
I get freaked out.
Alright, I'll have 30 seconds
to identify what this is.
Alright. You can look at it,
if you want.
-Oh! I can?
-Yeah, you just
can't tell me what it is.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
Good luck.
[ Laughter ]
-Aah!
Don't say that.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
It's so weird, I can't even
tell you how weird it is.
It's so weird.
Ugh!
I don't like it.
But it doesn't feel like
it's warm, or anything.
Ugh! Aah!
[ Laughter ]
Did I touch it?
Oh! Ew! Gross!
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's like a cold liquid.
-Go ahead.
[ Laughter ]
-What do you mean, "Go ahead"?
Go in it?
-[ Laughs ]
-I have to go in the liquid?
[ Laughter ]
It's water.
What's in it?
-Mmm!
Mmm!
Yum!
-This is so -- I'm done.
What is it?
[ Buzzer ]
Ew!
[ Laughter and applause ]
[ Sad trombone plays ]
♪♪
[ Cymbals crash ]
Oh, my God.
-Yummy.
-Oh, gross!
I mean, I do like eggnog,
but, no, I don't want
to put my hand in it.
Nicole, you're up.
-So, you lost that one?
-Yeah, but, you know...
-Okay.
-...let's play as a team,
you know?
-No, no.
[ Laughter ]
Alright, Nicole,
now you're not afraid?
You're not afraid of this
at all.
You're totally calm.
You're cool.
[ Laughter ]
-Stop.
[ Applause ]
-You're cool, right?
-It smells terrible.
There's an odd smell.
-It has an odd smell to it,
yeah, that's absolutely right.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
[ Drumroll ]
-Oh, don't.
Is there anything in there?
Aah!
[ Laughter ]
So I am frightened now.
-Did you touch it?
Did you touch it? [ Laughs ]
No, no, it's not bad.
It's not bad.
It's only Round 1. Trust me.
-I can't afford to lose any
of my fingers.
-I know, I understand,
I know. Hoo.
-Aah!
[ Laughter ]
You didn't touch anything.
-I'm really brave.
Oh!
-Oh, my God!
-I'm done.
It's some sort of animal.
It's a bird.
[ Laughter ]
[ Buzzer ]
Okay.
-"It's a bird."
-Oh, you're so bad!
[ Sad trombone plays ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
-[ Laughing ]
-I thought it was an animal.
You're so bad!
-Alright, here we go.
Aah!
-No.
-Aah!
Alright, here we go.
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
Oof.
[ Ohs and applause ]
♪♪
Don't do it.
-Just don't do it, right?
-Oh, my gosh!
Don't do it.
[ Laughter ]
It's terrifying.
♪♪
-What's -- I'm --
[ Laughter ]
-Come on.
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Gross!
♪♪
-Aah!
-Is it like worms or something,
maggots or something?
-Worse. Worse.
-Worse than that?
-Worse.
-Worse than maggots and worms?
♪♪
Everyone's grossed out.
I have no idea.
How can I guess this?
What? What is it?
-Oh, God.
-Yeah!
-Ha ha ha!
[ Buzzer ]
[ Laughter and applause ]
♪♪
Aah!
-You scared me.
-Yeah.
-Nail clippings?
Get this away from me.
This is the grossest.
I'm freaking out.
-I was pretending
it was some sort of -- yeah.
-You did. You actually did,
but I saw blood rush
to your face.
You were really scared.
-Yes.
-That's how good
of an actor you are.
[ Laughter ]
-Yes.
♪♪
[ Suspenseful music plays ]
This is a horrible game.
I hate it and I'll
never play it again.
-No, go, go, now.
-I'll never play it again.
-Now's the time to go.
That side, that side.
-Really?!
-Yes.
[ Drumroll ]
-Oh!
[ Laughter ]
What is that?!
-No, no, you have to touch it.
You have to feel it.
-I'm not!
-That's the whole game.
-Help me, guys, please.
♪♪
-Ohh!
-[ Laughing ]
-I'm truly terrified.
Awful.
-It's the most frightening
game ever.
-I hate this game
and I will --
-Oh, my God.
Never play it again.
-Yeah, you can tell.
I'm so serious.
-You can just know what it is.
-Alright, did we get it?
-Yes, you can know what it is.
-Alright, what is it?
-It's a funny little Santa Claus
that spins around.
-Oh, okay.
[ Buzzer ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
You guys --
[ Sad trombone ]
-Alright.
We're both going
to get the same item.
The first person to guess it
wins the whole thing.
Let's do this.
-I can't believe
what a coward I am.
-Ah. Right?
-Yeah.
-Right?
Because you came in hot.
You came in very confident.
-I did.
I did, and I lost.
[ Audience ohs ]
Oh, come on.
The audience is acting.
Now the audience --
[ Laughter ]
Now the audience is acting.
-Yeah.
-And, now,
I don't know what to do.
-Now you're really bad.
-The audience is, yeah,
they're acting it up.
-But why is the box so big?
-Why is the box so big?
-[ Laughs ]
-Alright.
[ Audience ohs ]
-Are you kidding?
-Ohh!
-Aah!
[ Laughter and applause ]
It's warm.
It's warm in there.
Something sweaty
and hot and sweaty in there.
[ Laughter ]
-Right?
-Hot.
♪♪
-Lower.
[ Cheering ]
♪♪
-Whoa!
It does feel hot.
-It's like liquid.
It's probably like --
What is it, like a frog
or something in there?
[ Laughter ]
Or water? It's water.
-Water?
-Yeah.
-Go down.
-Okay.
-Down.
-Lower!
[ Cheering ]
-Did you get it? Are you --
-Go down!
-Ah.
[ Laughter ]
It's you.
-Thank God it's you.
The whole time.
I think we're going to call it
a tie on this.
-No!
-[All] No!
-What is it?
-I don't know.
They want us to try to feel it.
-Hot water.
-Down!
-How water?
[ Shouting ]
-Go, go, go, go, go, go!
-Aah!
[ Laughter ]
-Did I touch it?
-Come on, guys.
-I have no idea what it is.
I can't do it.
-Aah!
-It's just water.
-It's water.
-Hot water, steam.
-Oh, my goodness gracious.
Are you --
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Ohh!
-I'm sorry.
I would never do that.
[ Sad trombone plays ]
I would never in my life
do that to you.
-You're in so much trouble.
-I would never do that to you.
I would never do that to you.
I didn't know!
I didn't know anything
about this!
That is insane. I don't even
know what that is. An eel?!
-That is illegal!
-I'm sorry. I'm sorry.
That is lethal.
Of course it is.
Oh, my God.
My thanks to Nicole Kidman.
We're talking to her
after the break.